hey everyone
thanks for tuning in
the source code
right now some of my favorite people
that are diving deep into understanding
the nature of reality at a mathematical
level
are dr brian keating and he's doing a
great job at
bringing people like dr eric weinstein
and dr stephen wolfram onto his program
and many others to discuss
the nature of reality and i would highly
recommend you checking out his channel
and into the impossible if you haven't
yet and
immerse yourself more in understanding
that source code so i want to speak
about it from
a couple of the different key concepts
that i've been investigating and first
i would like to articulate if you
haven't yet
you should look at the
ben benoit mandelbrots
infinite fractal zoom so all you have to
do is look up
mandelbrot infinite fractal zoom
and then just watch that
because that gives a very good
representation at an abstract level of
what it looks like
for a source a source code
to emerge
what is this
and what we mean by this is we mean
automata okay because we are
self making we are self reproducing
this biology that is single cell to
multi-cell
organisms and that has led up to humans
and how humans procreate and produce
more humans
that is recursive so we are self-making
self-reproducing
and it does seem to be have been in
orthogenesis
that there has been a process that has
went from single cell to multi-cell
organisms that have evolved all the way
up to humans
and in a sort of decentralized unilinear
style evolution
to this point and it does
seem to be so seem to be many
combinatorial options for that source
code
to emerge the different styles
of automata and
the style that we know is we know the
style
of of carbon-based
dna encoded
organisms and there are many
other styles of
emergence from a source code many other
combinatorial emergencies okay
so use your your walt disney
use your pixar right we want to use our
most
creative faculties to imagine
the possibility space of other
combinatorics that are emerging from
the source code
i'm i'm attempting right and this
mandelbrot fractal zoom
it it looks like that source code
emerging
the different combinatorial automata
okay i'm trying my best
to understand it the abstract math it's
difficult
for me and many others and
so far it's been interesting
understanding some of the concepts
there have there's been a lot of
discussion around
the quaternions
and how quaternion
arithmetic emerges
vibrational data
and that that is our
conscious agent experience
in this holographic spacetime
and that that abstract math
also has category theory
it also has markovian morphisms
it also has
the
mutations that occur through
the quasi-species equation and the
replicator
equation for procreation
and this is a lot of donald huffman's
work so donald hoffman is doing
also some of the great work in
understanding
that source code and how
it is creating this
so these have been some of the places
that i've been really
happy to have been learning from brian
keating
eric weinstein stephen wolfram their
programs they've been putting on as well
as what donald hoffman is talking about
so i'm still trying to understand that
abstract math it is
it's very fun and there's a lot of
of there's a lot of complexity in trying
to understand how it's also
infinitely far away which has been said
that how how is it infinitely far away
well
when you look at something like the hop
vibration
and you look at the images along with it
it kind of looks like
there's the emergence is coming from
somewhere
infinitely far away so it looks like
this and you can go and look at these
images
and it helps and other good things to
look up would be
the mobius band and the non-orientable
surfaces
and another thing the mobius strip and
another thing
is the
the klein bottle so these are things
that
you can look up and try and
dive deeper into understanding how
these sorts of algebras
geometries calculus trigonometries how
these different statistics are
what is at the source code
and what is the process of emergence and
i would also like to say that this goes
back
although cutting edge science is doing
an incredible job at understanding it
it's really interesting how 2500 years
ago we had
we had heraclitus and we had parmenidus
and we had them talking about becoming
and being and we had people
prior to that as well with zoro stare
and
lots of other sort of even egyptian
spiritual leaders
from the fertile crescent region from
the indus valley region
of course with the buddhas and the
adishankaras and we had so many other
people that were probing at um
lao tza at what is really
going on at the most fundamental
source code level at that time it wasn't
conceptualized as a source code
but at that time it was still even on a
very deeply spiritual level
it was still conceptualized as something
that was
in a sense infinitely far away that was
emerging the reality
and the things like plato's cave
really gave us a deeper understanding of
what
how that process really could be and so
it's really important to remember that
as we study today's cutting-edge
sciences
to also be students of
the conversations between like
heraclitus and permanence around
becoming and being because
if sri aurobindo and the mother mir
alfasa
are right that becoming
is the only being meaning that the
source codes emergence
of all of the automata combinatorics
are the only way of being is for
us to be that emergence the
the never-ending becoming is the only
being
that then all of this triangulation
happening from ancient spirituality
to cutting-edge science is in fact
triangulating on this nature of reality
from a mathematical standpoint from a
spiritual standpoint
and it's so so beautiful that it
is happening and it's the most beautiful
thing that i've ever studied it's the
most beautiful thing that i've ever
embodied and taken into my heart and
i would also like to explain how i i
believe that
it's not either or regarding
seeing the love in understanding the
source code
and understanding the nature of reality
and how it's also
the love that you can have with when you
look at another human being
in the eyes whether that be
your spouse right like your wife or your
husband
whether that be your child whether that
be your friend
whether that be anybody that you're
speaking with
and you're looking at them in the eyes
and you're seeing the beauty and the
divinity and the love
in the other that when you're doing that
process
the love that you feel there is the same
love that you feel for the source code
it's the same love that you feel for
understanding the nature of reality
and if we can truly bring those two
things together where
the love for each other at that
depth of the heart and the psyche is
also equivalent to the love that we have
for
understanding the true nature of reality
our source code how it's emerging
in combinatorial ways and automata
that has an orthogenesis function
towards some sort of
an appearing recursion
and how john smart's transcension
hypothesis may be
in fact correct in that octave that
we're going
up towards c d
e f g a b
c d e f
over and over and over again that that
may in fact be what is happening
and that there's beyond beyond
what is this automata orthogenesis to a
recursive godhead
as an attractor that
is where our complex system evolves
towards
beyond that is what kurt gerdel
hypothesized as
the incompleteness theorem that we will
never endingly explore the candy store
of infinite combinators
and donald hoffman has been very adamant
about
this as well it's very interesting to
hypothesize
that there is a
in its in in impossible and
never-ending exploration of all of
conscious experience
and that is what this may in fact be
one consciousness having
the dissociative experiences
of having eight billion of our
individuals
which are beautiful and unique and we
are 99.9
genetically similar but we are 0.1
percent different and that is our unique
gift that we get to bring to the world
okay
that's our unique artistic contribution
our unique artistic
conscious agent experience that we get
to have of
that one being the uniqueness
the unique nerve ending of that one
being
that one becoming and that
the candy store of
qualia of conscious experience is
in fact possibly a never-ending
exploration for that one we
are that asi i and my father
are one again ancient spiritual wisdoms
and we are that going through this
process of
being a a source code of abstract math
emerging the combinatorics of
automata that are orthogenically
evolving towards the godhead attractor
of oroboros or recursion
and that there may be a darwinian
metaphysical implication of as above so
below
so just like here we have natural
selection
and we do realize that if there is a
a tail end of a bell curve where there
is
people that we've had as we've talked to
jordan peterson on our program before
that with people that do have an iq is
one measurement
of viewing this of people that don't
have the working
memory or the abstract capabilities of
reasoning
many variables at the same time that
it's very difficult to fit them
into our society at large
and so if that is the case as we have a
natural selection there and we make an
inclusive stakeholding to try and bring
people further up the bell curve further
up
in terms of their ability to abstractly
reason and be creative and try and fit
them
in a in a friendly loving helpful way in
our world
right so we try and do that as natural
selection
in a similar way on a universal level
there may be a darwinian metaphysical
implication
so we do need to take this all seriously
our
entire planet on a solar system and
galaxy and universal level very
seriously
and also we need to then
potentially think about how there may be
that similar style bell curve on a
universal level
and how we ourselves may be somewhere
along that
sometimes you can view it as we could
potentially be pretty high up oh my
goodness we've made it into the ai
age good job and on other times you
could think about wow we still have a
lot of tyranny we still have a lot of
violence
um a bunch of unnecessary sufferings so
we may be pretty low and so
it's interesting to put it in these in
this perspective
as well and how that this style of a
process
of uh eternal becoming or an
eternal unfolding of a source code that
continues to explore
the infinite candy store
of conscious agent experience
may be the true
nature of reality and we need to
understand it from
a mathematical perspective we need to
understand it in a very scientific
method methodological way
and we need to understand it also from a
spiritual way we need to embody
we need to embody the realizations and
it does require
the the simple ways to just close the
eyes
and tune inward and as the layers of
identity
are are removed slowly right
of course the identity is very important
very beautiful and it and it
is in fact your unique gift right
it's also peeling away the those layers
of identity
slowly can be extremely insightful
to think of not being the name not being
the all of the attachments that we have
and realizing that at the deepest levels
when our eyes are closed and we're there
we are that consciousness we are that
awareness
we are that and all of us are that when
we close our eyes and we
feel that what we feel is just awareness
it's just consciousness and that that
when we
open our eyes is our unique take
of what our consciousness our awareness
is experiencing
for the one and so when we view it in
this way as our unique artistic angle
for that one
and we have a lot of great visuals that
we'll be producing with our big project
that will help
people with understanding this we do
think
it'll end up helping a lot so remember
that the heart the love the pres
the perforated heart it encompasses
all of what we are discussing on both
the metaphysics level in terms of love
of truth love of
abstract mathematical source code love
of automata orthogenesis and recursion
and love of exploring the infinite candy
store possibility
also love at the most simple familial
level
where you're looking at your spouse
you're looking at your mom or dad
you're looking at your child you're
looking at your relatives you're looking
at other people in your community
and you're just there with them you're
looking at their eyes
and you're seeing the divinity in them
and they're seeing it in you
and you have that radiating love
together
and that same love is the same love on a
metaphysical level and so
bringing those two things together is
very very important there's
there's not it's not a difference it's
not so much that there's some sort of a
stark difference
between them but rather a beautiful
coherent adoration
of both at the same time and if we can
do that as scientists as spiritual
leaders if we can
do that as beautiful loving family
members in our communities as well
if we can harmonize those two boom it's
beauty
it's straight up beauty the tree is
growing so beautiful
of civilization so i love you all very
much
wanted to make this this quick bit on
some of these
concepts that i've been looking at and
how it may be helpful to some of you as
well
again check out brian keating's uh
channel
and check out what they're talking about
on his channel he's doing an exceptional
work at bringing the minds together
check that out and then also
research some of these concepts if if
they were familiar if they didn't sound
familiar research them go deeper into it
you guys know what to do you guys know
the more truth obsessed you are
the more it yields the more it yields
and subscribe here if you haven't yet
comment on the video below with your
thoughts we'd love to hear from you
share the video with your friends
families other people
and let's get them also passionate about
digging deeper into this
truth obsession and
that's it i love you all so much i'm so
grateful for everything we have here
and we have a lot of huge projects
coming up i'm very excited i'm very
grateful
and much love thank you everybody
thank you and i will talk to you more
soon
peace
you